hi my name is Bob Lee I'm the core
library lead for Android and I'm here to
show off a couple of my favorite Android
features I spend most of my time in the
web browser I can keep up with my
friends on Twitter or I can switch
windows using androids window feature
and keep up with the latest news on
Google Reader here we go we're following
politics because we have the upcoming
election I can scroll through and look
at the items until I find an item I'm
interested in here's one by Esther Dyson
for example I can click on the item and
it automatically expands using Ajax I
can scroll through the item and I can
read it here and what the size of the
screen and whatnot it's very easy to
read full stories I can scroll down and
I can if I want to look at the original
web page all I have to do is click the
see original link and Android's browser
opens up that web page in a different
window when I'm not coding on Android
I'm an aspiring photographer so I love
the fact that you can copy I can copy my
photos onto the SD card and pull them up
in the picture app so and then show them
off to my friends here's a picture of my
favorite subject and I just click the
arrow buttons and I can navigate through
the pictures or I can click menu and
then tap slideshow and it'll go through
them automatically